san francisco is so full of crap
it's giving every fish a dirt nap
i know
yeah here's the scoop on sf's leading
export poop
human excrement my nickname for my
interns
is also apparently
it's also apparently feeding a major
algae growth in the bay area basically
they're creating a floating island of
poop i know i know charlie it sounds
awesome but hold on
it's killing thousands of fish
and that's bad
at first scientists blame climate change
for the algae that showed up in july but
now they're pointing the finger at the
85 million gallons of fecal matter being
pumped daily into the bay area and
that's just from nancy pelosi's house
thought i was going to say ass didn't
you
but apparently sewage treatment plants
are so old and inept they can't handle
the load
sounds like the president
but the problem has gotten so bad tens
of thousands of fish are dying and it's
gonna cost california 14 billion dollars
to upgrade the sewage system we caught
up with one of the main culprits
so the city has this algae problem do
you feel responsible
hey i can't take all the credit i'm just
one small cog in the massive san fran
machine but i do want to shout out my
sponsors starbucks chipotle and major
props to buffalo wild wings
so no remorse at all and no plans to
curb this behavior
oh absolutely not san francisco was just
the tip of the turdburg we're taking
this on the road this fall i've got
stops in utah we're dropping those kids
off right in that salt lake baby uh
let's see i also want to off the st
louis arch and we're definitely in the
alamo they're going to remember it now
um anything else
uh what can i say i'm franchising i'm
merchandising so you all better be
sanitizing don't forget to like comment
subscribe turn man of alcatraz at
geocities.edu
cyrus you knew we were gonna do this
story oh i think everyone in this
building knew you were gonna do this
when i thought poop when i thought poop
island well i was like we're in this
yeah you were you were in knee deep that
was it yes yeah isn't it amazing how
everything in the bay area is now like
turning into poop like it's all about
poop well well i mean it's california in
general uh is just loaded
and uh you know
bubonic plague is back yeah you know
from that and uh what sucks is the algae
that sucks up all the oxygen it doesn't
just kill the fish it makes the water
toxic which eventually will end up back
in your homes so then our our children
will have problems with their teeth
they'll have problems growing because
the water is going to be so
toxified so it's a horrible problem and
again it's only in california anywhere
else it would they could probably fix
something with a couple million dollars
why is in california it's always 14
billion dollars to fix anything and even
then they never fixed it i used to go to
la zoo when i was a kid it's still under
construction
well they have to hire all the dei
officers to make sure the poop is yeah
uh shuffled in an equitable way yeah
that is true
why can't this is the world i think
corey this is the world's like richest
zip code and they can't handle their own
poop what's up i mean well it doesn't
surprise me all that much i do avoid san
francisco like the bubonic plague
because you go into the streets and
there's excrement all over the place so
i didn't it wasn't surprising that you
have all these problems but i think
they're going to fix their problem
themselves with their big government
policies and increasing taxes
because this is already driving people
away look they're saying that this
problem is caused by
high population density and people
already leaving the u.s census bureau
already reported from 2020 to 2021 san
francisco was the the number one major
city with the biggest population loss
over that period six percent loss
amazing so people they keep driving
people away this problem will solve
itself in the long run i have to
disagree with you that i think the
homeless are are pooping on the streets
to save the fish that's right
from
from having to live any longer yes no
they're just like they know that they're
not going to want them
they don't want to grow the algae bloom
so they're pooping on the streets
they're just people i mean did you no no
i don't think anyone saw that yes
no it's amazing um but but you can't
divorce it from the politics yeah i mean
these cities are the resume of democrats
every one of them they everything they
touch turns to calcutta yeah and you
know the idea of clean water drinking
water and a closed sewage system is like
a hallmark of civilization yeah and in
all of these democrat-led cities they're
they they are abandoning basic
civilization i do think it's kind of
interesting one little aspect of this is
that uh at a time that a lot of people
don't talk about this but we also are
having a war on fertilizer yes in this
country and it's going to cause massive
problems that we can only begin to
imagine right now and what i mean you
have a problem with too much fertilizer
winding up in the bay yes and farmers
literally cannot afford fertilizer to
grow their crops in the rest of the
country and a pipeline you're saying
you're you're talking about a pipeline
a poop pipeline
charlie
is that where you were going right
that's where you were going a poop
pipeline from the bay area to the farms
i i i think there's something there but
i'm not going to go on this business
venture with you you realize you can't
come back right you're banned that is a
brilliant idea and i think it should be
called the gut pipeline i think it's
great the gut felt pipeline is great
just under your gut poop it out into the
farms
compost i really like this job i did
[Laughter]
emily i think this is also what happens
when you blame everything on one thing
like they blame everything on climate
change or republicans or racism and then
you never solve underlying problems this
could have been solved if somebody said
hey look we have a problem with our
sanitation system but no it's climate
change yeah it's when common sense flies
out the window this breaks my heart you
know i'm from there you know that my
grandparents immigrated from sicily to
san francisco and then now it literally
is a piece of
the reason that it was it used to be you
know the most beautiful city in the
world right it was absolutely stunning
it was so expensive to live there right
they shut out and pushed out a lot of
working-class families because all of a
sudden the rich wanted to live there and
to me it's such an analogy the marina is
actually a landfill right they built it
on begin with and it reminds me sort of
that movie shallow howl that awesome
movie where the inside of you like that
it shows the inside of you and here the
actual inside their terrible policies
their oversimplification the refusal to
use common sense the power hungry the
power grab of gavin newsom and those
five families of
nancy pelosi and kamala everyone that
grew up from there in the political
scene that actually was never serving
working-class americans now the inside
is showing out and the fish are dying
and it's all filled with crap and we're
supposed to accept it note that the cost
by the way that's passed on to the
taxpayers there you go yeah
ladies got a mouth on her
we're gonna have to have a talk later
about your dirty mouth
coming up she won grand slams in
wimbledon but thinks that i'm a
simpleton hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else